how do you deal with rude people on
Facebook there's a question I got from
one of my YouTube viewers Colin Colin is
great Colin is always asking questions
always comment on the video so Colin I
owe you a special video to answer your
question here here's the thing okay the
more popular you get the more you're
gonna have haters the Morgan got people
who are jealous of what you do there
they're insecure in what they're all
about and so they feel a need to leave
rude comments or to hate on what you're
all about it's gonna happen so I almost
think of it as a badge of honor
you know I finally got to the point
where people want to leave hate messages
and angry messages and rude messages
about what I'm talking about
it means you've gotten somewhere you
haven't an impact
there's a couple things that I do and
maybe there's something here you can
learn from okay the first thing I do is
most of the comments I'll just ignore
now I don't get that many negative
comments I still get some but for the
most part the comments are really
positive and I love seeing them come in
and they make my day and I love engaging
with you guys
for anybody who's asking a question
you'll see I usually respond either
writing or with the video but I do get
some negative ones and usually what I'll
do is just ignore them you know you
wanna you want to be negative you live
in your negative space okay I don't
engage with that I don't need negative
people around me I've cut out a ton of
negative people in my life and I don't
need you bringing me down
so I just let them roll off my back the
second thing I'll do if I'm feeling a
little cheeky and depending on what the
comment is is I'll respond with either a
happy face or an lol or something like
that what's funny is a lot of times my
audience will come to my defense if
somebody leaves a comment on YouTube
that says Evan you don't you're talking
about or Evan that doesn't make any
sense or some you know I don't know some
random comment that is not not good even
if I don't say anything you guys jump to
my defense and get in there and are calm
retain and say you don't know what
you're talking about and I love it I
love seeing you guys coming in my
defense I love that I've helped inspire
that and so keep doing that it's great
it makes me chuckle every time I see
that happening
the third thing I'll do is if I feel
like there's a lesson to be learned I'll
create content or create a video about
it
so I had a lot of times that the
messages are just there's no there's
nothing you can do about it you know
like the comments are just so so
unrelated and so unhelpful that there's
not worth even bringing up but but on
some occasions there's a belief behind
it that could be address because other
people have the same belief and you can
use it as a teaching moment to help your
audience so remember I had one viewer
who wrote in and I made a video on this
I wrote I said in one of my videos that
starting the business as heart and this
guy wrote back to say starting a
business is hard how demotivational you
know why why aren't you building up
entrepreneurs and I made a video as a
teaching moment because starting
business is hard and I wish somebody had
told me how difficult would be because
the books movies TV shows I'll make it
look so easy and I hit a huge wall where
I thought I was the only guy who sucked
at business when I first started my
company and I wish I knew how difficult
it was gonna be and so I used that video
as a teaching moment I don't care about
him I don't care about that guy who
wrote in I don't care if he watches it I
don't care if he learns from it but it's
something that everybody who's on the
channel can learn from you guys who are
watching kind of learn from it because
if you think that starting a business is
easy then you need to be told because
you're gonna set yourself up for really
unrealistic expectations when it starts
getting hard with your company so those
are three main things I'll do the first
again ignore the second some kind of
cheeky you know happy face lol and I
don't really engage in a verbal dispute
back and forth and three if I think is a
teaching moment for the rest of my
audience then I'll make a video about it
or create a create some content about it
the last option I guess is if I feel
like the comment is is is just hate is
inappropriate
you know if it's racially motivated or
religiously motivated or just something
that is totally inappropriate
I won't delete a comment if you think
I'm stupid or if you think what I'm
saying is stupid or
disagree with my opinion that's cool but
if you start you start bringing
something in that that is racially
motivated or just something that doesn't
belong on there you know just pure hate
then I'll delete the comment but
otherwise I usually let them stand so
hopefully that helps that's what I do
hopefully you get a lot more positive
feedback than negative it means you're
on the right track who those you're
watching liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below it makes you always
want to do more for you and please leave
a comment underneath a good one let me
know you liked the video you have a
question let me know you a video
response thank you so much guys thank
you calling for the great question and I
will see you soon